I've had a nose job I've had a nose job
I have had a nose job I've had a nose
[Music]
job hey hey hey hey hey okay
okay nose straighter than a linear
[Laughter]
[Applause]
equation car's nose was beautiful oh oh
my God her nose was gorgeous stunning
beautiful eyes let's see
it Swip look my eyes oh okay that was SM
SM that's actually a good one for me
wow real OH Close okay he had a little
bit of a bump from having like something
like not heal properly with your
rhinoplasty let's go
beautiful beautiful love it love it and
for you gorgeous wonderful and then when
Devon like did one of like the walks I
looked I was like I don't know like she
is like very pretty because like it's
uniform all right let's see what we got
what's going front
view side view you know and then the
side
[Music]
view
the fact that he was just so willingly
able to just push it up definitely made
me suspicious of him right
away he was standing right next to me
and I kept hearing him heavy breathing
and I couldn't tell if it was like he
just got a nose job and like he can't
like breathe still or like he just has
nasal like problems that hurt that it
was hurt it was painful when did
everyone get their surgery like let's
just go down the line like say the date
you got it the day and the hour and the
well like I I got mine December 18th
2018 so that's was 5 years ago yeah I
got mine June 19th 2019 I got mine
December 30th and this year or yeah this
year like 202
2023 wait well I mean 2022 sorry guys I
just get confused December 30th cuz then
January 1st I couldn't go out cuz I oh
okay I got mine January 14th of 2022
right after New Year's and the
holidays um September 30th 2019 right
before my semester how much did you guys
pay since we all got like different
states I feel like it varies I know it's
more expensive like in
California I went to multiple
consultations and it was like one went
from literally like
$33,000 to literally like it went down
to like 14,000 15,000 and that's what we
end up charging 13 14,000 in Beverly
Hills yep oh wait you're I've never
heard of that you're going to be shocked
at my price I no mine was only 125 cuz I
got it in Boston and it was really good
oh that's amazing yeah it's really cheap
good mine was 14 mine was 8K I also got
um my septum and like all that other
stuff that I needed to get fixed cuz I
had like sleep apnea mine was 18K but I
know he charges more now o well did you
guys get closed or open open closed yeah
mine was closed I got open
I had zero idea what that meant so why
did you guys all get your surgery I got
it 50% for Aesthetics I had a big hump
but I think the main reason I got it is
my biological father just isn't a great
person and I don't associate with him
anymore he's Italian and I just like had
his nose after I got the surgery in 2018
it was kind of like me like cutting the
cord and just being like okay like I'm
no longer his daughter like I'm my own
person you know so it was really like
freeing and and it looked better too so
was great thank you thank you I mean I
don't want to say she made it up but it
just seemed like if I do something for
myself it's for myself not because I'm
doing it for that other person
especially in a in a situation like that
I got mine cuz like my sister has a
perfect nose and it's kind of funny you
said that like I feel like I got my
dad's and she got my mom's so I was like
absolutely not like how do you have that
and I have this and it was like pretty
common like I knew a couple people had
it so it wasn't like something major to
be done in Middle School like growing up
like people always had really negative
comments and I like just felt so bad
about myself and I never showed my face
in photos cuz I'm like 17 I'm in high
school and everything so you were
bullied into getting one well I feel
yeah I guess and I just felt like really
awful about myself and I know like I
never was going to feel like really that
good about myself until I got this one
thing fixed about myself and even though
I'm so young like I know that it will
benefit my future I don't think you
needed it cuz I can I imagine you not
looking good thank you look so good
thank you I'm Lebanese and I just
naturally have a larger nose I wanted to
look more like my brother's nose cuz he
had like the perfect nose in the family
I was like well if his looks like that
nobody's going to like think twice and
be like oh well he got his done too but
yeah I just wanted to get it
done M what's that smell you think you
sniffed out the mole well make sure to
subscribe to this Channel and like this
video and wait till the end to find
out she wanted to make herself the
center of conversation which to me that
kind of put a spotlight on
her I wasn't really sure about his nose
when he pushed it up I think you can
sometimes do that with silicone but he
like really went up
there
bye what the how I felt about the guys
getting voted out first it I kind of saw
that coming but in this day and age it's
like super common now you can never
really guess who who has or hasn't
please raise your hand if you want to
continue the
game wait so did everyone say they got
closed I got open it closed yeah I got
open oh you got open do you guys have
any scars or do you choid cuz I choid
like really really easily no mine's on
the inside I feel like my recovery
wasn't that bad like to be honest I
think Clos is faster cuz open requires
more yeah yeah mine was open because I
had so much work done to it and like the
whole bottom was all droopy and then it
just got brought up so this whole part
was like fixed like under here like no
scar yeah it I try to cover up as much
as I can and then this part it was super
like wide so they completely broke this
like bridge and like completely just
like swished it in she didn't know like
what she was talking about but then I
also was thinking I literally just think
this squir just got a nose job and like
didn't care she just like got it and
didn't have to know any of the stuff I
actually have a scar I can show you guys
I wore this shirt with an intention but
you see this I like koid yeah so it's
still there and then I have like a small
White Scar under here and it hasn't even
like been a year for you guys and I
don't know my doctor told me like your
nose fully heals after a year so like it
could still like go like yeah I would
say like the whole first year like mine
would keep swelling up like every time I
cried or when I drank when I drank my
yeah it was bad even in the morning I
feel yes when I up my fingers look like
and I like try to like massage it to
like make all of it like calm down I
didn't want to like leave I feel like
nobody talks about like the posttop
anxiety and depression that comes after
like I know they tell you you're going
to be swollen it's going to take a year
don't worry but you're looking at
yourself like every day I was
obsessively taking photos every single
day I honestly when they like did the
reveal I he said it was going to be
swollen but I didn't like the way it
looked so I was kind of like H yeah so
many surgeons have videos of that and so
I was expecting that moment I was like
I'm going to look so good like the Asian
like Angelina right here so does anyone
like regret their decision their
rhinoplasty at first like I did like I
was just like I feel bad for spending
all my parents money I was like I made a
mistake like maybe this wasn't for me
but then I let it do its thing and I
don't regret it at all best decision of
my life I feel like I kind of regretted
it a little bit cuz I felt like I was
like young like at 18 and then like I
felt like as my face was like maturing I
feel like it's not like perfect like the
way I would like so I feel like I should
have waited a little bit longer after
the surgery I had like a really bad
recovery process they had a difficult
time waking me up from the anesthesia
cuz that was my first time under so they
like the anesthesiologist was shaking me
and saying like they the wake up and
that was terrifying and I was like but
then afterwards I I I wouldn't change it
for the world so I feel like mine was
just more uncomfortable like I didn't
have like the splints or anything like
mine was just like a top cast and like I
just had gauze in the bottom to like
stop the bleeding and stuff like that so
mine wasn't that
bad she just made it seem like it was
not a big deal at all even in closed
nose jobs there's definitely a recovery
process that you have to go
through bye ladies please raise your
hand if you want to continue playing the
game if the lights turn green that means
you have voted out the mole and you win
if the lights turn red that means the
mole is still in the box and you
[Music]
lose oh my okay thank you thank you oh
my gosh 3 2 1 I knew it I knew it so
much I know God literally such a
Li when you said your sister had a
perfect nose I was like I'm the sister
with the perfect nose no I'm sorry sis
no I have never considered nose job I
honestly like wanted to do this cuz I
get asked all the time if I've had one
and I'm like this is natural so I
thought that this was like my game to
win dang it I knew it was her uh I can't
write skateboards so I tried uh writing
skateboards where I'm from it's very
hilly speed Wes ate it rolled like
probably like 20 30 yards just like just
tumbled bro broke my goddamn
nose then she got smoked I do think that
there's a negative stigma around nose
jobs there's just a lack of transparency
and I feel like a lot of people think
that you must be like really insecure if
you get it done or you don't like how
you look like you hate it and that's
definitely not the
[Applause]
case
dang know for our next nose job I'm
kidding for
our this is not even enough for your
consultation right oh my
gosh too
much